that's the best way to lose votes with
blackish she was pandering everybody in
the room know it when they said what are
you carrying the purse they would have
had more respect for her if she said
well thank you your people I carry mace
all right glad to have why I always said
that but okay this is what let me
introduce this this next guest usually
we give a lot of plugs really obvious he
has a tremendous podcast the Nick
DiPaolo podcast follow him on Twitter at
Nick DiPaolo di PA o el the funniest man
alive for me my opinion I think he is
the funniest man walking granite earth
right now Nick sorry for the borderline
[ __ ] fangirl ISM are you there yeah
hell of an introduction there's nowhere
to go but down but did you just say
[ __ ] you could say that intereste
already know we can't I can cuz not gay
Jared can edit it so he can plan for it
but you have to be in a short leash
because we've listened to your podcast
man I mean it's it's one of the I think
we talked about this cuz thank you you
you played this rant that I did it at
UMass and I was unbelievably flattered
because of anything you know I was I was
channeling people from who I've grown up
on like like you you've dealt with this
since before I was born
do you feel like it has gotten worse
recently I know you want to college
campuses but even just in the last few
years because you're known for a guy who
pisses people off that's kind of your
brand
I guess my follow me it's before you
were born that kind of PC yeah it's got
him it's got progressively work I mean
like I told you I it stands up my first
my first open mic gig was like a 1987
and after about my third my probably my
third time on stage somebody goes yeah
you're kind of like totally incorrect
that's that's that's where it's headed
and you're in the right spot and and
even then I said the guy I don't thanks
doc I think it's nice and it's all to
get exponentially worse since we let
women vote but anyway you know it's
funny you said that you sort of I would
think that in 87 it was certainly more
open that was part of my rant right even
if you look at the hippies back then
they at least sort of tried to feign
like they
fighting for free speech kids on college
campus right now
you know not only were they not even
there for 9/11 nikka so this is even for
me
what just a few years removed it's just
sort of been assumed well hate speech
isn't acceptable offensive speech isn't
acceptable it's not even an issue to
them it's just assumed yeah we have to
limit speech so yeah I gotta imagine
from 87 are there to stark contrast
there opera 911 kite with the views like
that it kind of makes you wish they were
doing some banking in the sunglass hut
juice God we're gonna get letters look
they've been brainwashed if you watch
movies from the 80s you can see the the
liberal jerk-offs who make film at work
that's when it started to take over the
politically correct messages and in
movies right watch watch Philadelphia
with Tom Hanks yeah you want to want the
an attack on old white men in the
eighties with Reagan I think they had
free rent like the perfect samples
Philadelphia the AIDS thing it was never
an epidemic was never an epidemic that
your chances of getting AIDS unless
you're shooting dirty needles and having
gay orgies in a truck stall are
statistically less than 0% in the United
States they always have been and healthy
Haitian choreographers but a lot of
rugged construction you know this
happened material that's kept me doing
radio in my basement the last years but
I mean Trump look I'm not a huge fan and
stuff but you know he sort of won me
over just with a set of balls on him I
would have to sleep on the couch you
know six months ago and instead of he
was imitating that that reporter from
New York Times's just disabled guy
whatever I I almost fell off the couch
laughing no not that I want to make fun
of you know physically challenged people
I'm just saying is an investment price
care
you mentioned black lives matter before
he went to the break this is a big
when I was at not UMass before that
right I was at Cal Poly and we had bomb
threats and we had to have cops go
through black lives matter showed up and
in the paper they they fact checked my
jokes and asked me to check my privilege
and yeah it is that'll do college
campuses well I did one in Staten Island
but there you know Staten Island make
college in Staten Island it's like I
think I might have been I think it was a
DeVry black people my age like to know
where you stand
they like the crazy white comic who you
speak it as my right eye was this is
Arlington Virginia past weekend it was a
black eye right in the middle I mean
would look do-rag on oh thanks box he
was you I was playing for him I was
feeding off his energy the whole time
right laughing it and the more honest
those being the harder he was laughing
came up to me after the show that he
tweeted me and in light and this is true
in my 28 years don't stand up I swear to
God
I've had maybe 10 10 10 black people
walk out because they you know on my
show cuz they thought as if as opposed
to it I'm not kidding it's hundreds in
hundreds of white young kids right yeah
I don't see they're the ones that get
offended for the guy I'm totally honest
on stage no matter who's sitting in the
crowd right like like there's a good
example eree
you know at that black radio station
saying that she had hot sauce oh my gosh
we ran with that we had met Anna Lou
Blair morphine drip that's the best way
to lose both with laughter she was
pandering everybody in the room know it
when they said what are you carrying a
purse they would have had more respect
for her if she said well thanks to your
people I carry mace and you know and
they want to laugh their ass off and and
and elite that the black people I grew
up with it's not the same man if I can
convince you at all and maybe I can't
listen you know you're taking about but
there are kids out there who need to
hear someone like you they're just not
aware that you can say this stuff
they're terrified I'll fight
psychologists
yeah that it could be he has to be good
good money for me to go to a college and
be aggravated by these little fascists
do you follow mixed martial arts no I
know your sports guy but do you follow
like the UFC I choked out my wife last
night well no one does no I I watched a
little bit I know we're all him pretty
well
yes I'm not like an avid fan but it it's
funny when I first saw I still laugh but
I watched I grew up on watching boxing
well I watch at UFC it looks like yeah
it'd be two guys to bare feet in shorts
it look like they get in a fight at a
pool party I know even though they
disagree with you vehemently I can't
imagine someone like client or Karlin
saying Nick you shouldn't say this
because it's offensive I can't no you're
exactly right I can't imagine any
comedian saying that I mean that's I
mean it almost tells you that they DNA
they're really on a common IIIi don't
even yea even grasp it the twenty that
it's one of the fringe benefits of being
a comic yes I mean I I don't take it for
granted at all that I can say anything
you know one of the few people that you
go to work hey whatever you want right
and so so that was the order you you are
right in that mix but yeah Klein and
Carlin and obviously Cosby until you
know the kind of whole rape thing but
there are people like well you know he
raped he raped the equivalent to a small
Haitian village but shook his hand after
show in Atlantic City bucks fifteen
years ago next thing you know I wake up
I'm wearing nothing but a temple t-shirt
instead there's a bunch of pretty plop
Rapids if you like this clip it's taken
from the full-length podcast every week
you can click that box down below to
watch the full free video casts or
subscribe on iTunes to watch them the go
click my face to go to ladder with
better calm where we right plenty of
articles columns and upset those who are
easily triggered or click below me
there's some other video down there I
don't know what it is yet not gay Jarrod
is going to toss it's probably going to
be something
ambiguous but uncomfortable